TikTok is going to help you afford Christmas gifts for your children,
your spouse, and even yourself.
Go treat yourself. This is absolutely not fake.
I had to test it before I brought it to your attention.
Yes, everybody is talking about the purple ticket.
On your profile,
you're gonna see a tiny little purple ticket on the left top corner.
I'll show you what that looks like on the next screen.
But you can also take that link and put it in your links.
It has to be in the links.
If someone clicks that link or you text them that link,
you get $2 to a account. To an account in order to spend on TikTok Shop.
Y'all, it's real.
My sister's balance is insane right now.
If you get someone who has not signed up to TikTok yet
or downloaded the app on their phone
like my parents, my sister hijacked them,
you get $50 per person. Yes,
it's real.
And the same people can re click those links every three days.
On top of that, every time you get into TikTok,
every day, you can check in and get up to four dollars and thirty cents.
And then lastly,
you can click the brows button right here that I circled.
And you get 50 cents just for clicking on 10 different products.
Yes. At the end of the day,
their goal is to keep people on the app.
That is what every social media platform Does.
I've done digital marketing for many years,
so I know the marketing purpose behind that.
But most importantly,
if you wanna buy gifts for your kids like I already have,
and budget is tight right now. Guys,
I know we're all in the same situation,
you can utilize this to put money into your account
so that you can purchase TikTok products.
And also if you are wanting to start promote products.
Sorry. If you are wanting to promote products.
Usually when you start a business like this,
you have to invest money and buying products
so that you can make product reviews.
Well, in this case,
that money is going to be given to you
so you can buy products and make reviews.
Christmas gifts to yourself or your kids and make reviews.
This community is about supporting each other and our financial goals.
So for anyone who does tap my link and then comments
done in the comments, I will go and return the favor to you.
This is how we become best buddies on Tiki Tok.
It's so easy. Comment down,
I'll do it to you
and you're gonna see your account rise every single day.
And don't forget,
if you know someone who does not have it downloaded on their phone,
you get 50 bucks. You all know I used to work in financial advising.
You know that I promote women working from home
and I help them do so. And this is a big Opportunity!
So click the link, drop a comment,
and let's support each other! Merry Christmas!